hey the playoff intensity uh spilling
over into the expensive seats Matt
ishpia the owner of the sunsets not want
to give away that loose ball and the
Joker doesn't appreciate it no it's not
his balls
rare instances we're a two-time MVP
putting a forearm under the owner of the
other team I don't understand why he got
a technical
for uh
to throw in a putting a forearm on the
guy and putting him back in the seat I I
would I would guarantee that joker did
not know he first he was an owner
I agree with
the technical it was if it was any other
fan in the world
they wouldn't have gave him protected
first of all let me ask you a question
Ernie if there hadn't been a regular fan
he'd have got tossed the other guy got
tossed I know because he because he hit
Joker he touched him he didn't he yeah
okay but I'm saying though if another
fan wouldn't let the ball go he would
have got tossed
uh but you're not throwing me out of my
building
exactly no way uh by the way this is